okay so again the same thing that I
always say there's not two Arts okay so
as we come in already I'm reconciling my
materiality my energy that is working
through me going through my body onto
the ground vectors as we come in then I
yield so here's my angle
change my angle
change right but I'm not just trying to
get
out so as as I change my angle in other
words I don't leave his body there his
body is moving with me you see with my
with my
adhesions so that doesn't change as I
come around his body moves his body is
in is in me and I'm in his
body so you're not here trying to just
leave him
there you you're in his body in his body
from the start in his body for rest
start
here oh this is this
Ju
okay okay so already reconciling my own
energy connecting to his energy and
remember on ju n you're not accelerating
him you have you're going when you're
doing it for real you got to displace
this leg okay do you understand you're
you're not you don't go here you go
through this
leg
okay and that's going to require you
again in his body that's going to
require you again to as you feel his
mass that energy too has to be
internalized okay let's go okay so
continuing on yesterday
thing right uh always look for these
wrist locks in here people
uh will forget them and they should
always pay for touching you okay and so
as I go for my wrist locks here you
you'll find them
uh you'll let's say let's say I go for
the wrist lock and he pulls his arm out
now cuz he's he's trying to do uh
his stuff and it'll create openings do
you see that as he has to protect
himself okay you understand that so the
same thing like on
the on the
ground right and uh let's say uh I'm
doing this kind of stuff right and he's
got no choice but to try to create space
with the other arm cuz I'm pinning it
and he's got no space here so as he goes
to create space well that's where I'm
attacking the the wrist do you see and
so from that from that wrist attack I'm
I'm still attacking the wrist do you see
as I'm going into the mount and is a
much easier Mount than I'm find a mount
and he has pure 100% defense you got
that okay so on this one we'll go slow
but it's the same
thing take the y
space use your shoulder to put
push and my hand
catches the action here instead of
stepping in to attack the leg I step in
to keep contact with the elbow and
that's where I find
it yield again in his body so his body
is with me home body is with
me
okay let's get there all right so we
we're going to take the the the bottom
half
component of the of Jui nugget okay so I
have my lock in here and I because I
have attacking a leg you see you you
will have the throw again what what's
happening on his upper body is just
where wherever I'm touching that's
that's your IP adhesion that's where
you're in his body I do have a lock but
I'm not in the joint I have a lock here
but it's in his body do you see so iido
not don't attack you could if you want
you could attack The Joint but here I
just I'm using that joint in the same
way that where wherever I'm touching as
I'm in his body do you understand okay
so I'm using the joint and then I half
the
leg so slip attack The Joint you don't
have to put your wrist like that right
it is kind of like that because he
hooked
right got it okay I'm in here you might
have to step up again to get the right
Emi depth on the
leg notice that I kick back over the
top
okay let's go okay so this is the
front uh inward kazushi that you're
using okay and on the front inward
kazushi you you always attack this
leg which is really this hip okay any
anywhere from his hot down to Mid leg is
where where you come
in so you have you have your EO and
that's where you're coming in
here remember it's a body attack you're
not attacking the
arm you remember say yes I remember okay
so you're coming in here to attack the
leg so we do uh juji net and same thing
there here it is right here right
there's the
leg uh it doesn't matter I on me doesn't
matter there's the leg that's where I
come
in so just like in
E I don't bypass the leg to get the
arm on juj Naga same thing I'm not just
accelerating in by the arm
me not here
and this takes
the technique is I'm not attacking his
arm I would have to use my arms okay and
we're just using that principle here so
as I come
around on the first technique right I
again there it is right there just say
there please there's that triangle and
that's why I insert my triangle and
let's turn this so the camera can see
okay
I don't have to I don't want to parallel
you I'm going to attack this
leg so if you pay attention to my arms
on the first technique they don't do
anything they just stay United to my
body well the same thing is happening on
this technique get out of your arms as
you're going into the
lock don't pull the arm down you're
going to take the lock
off keep the lock on and attack the
leg the only arm movement comes after
for that final cooku projection
okay so here
here slip in don't undo the lock keep
the lock and attack the
leg then the arm movement comes on that
okay let try it again